дебати між прем'єр-міністром
нідерландів марку морю то й правим
популістам герт вілдерс він головні
конкуренти парламентських виборів
безкомпромісну свою риторику на
підвиборки фінішної премії території до
вийшла за ми ж внутрішню політику
турка ще більше посилити ескалацію ми
панель у тані по ви не просто стоять та й
коза ти проникливість аскола типовий
не вигляд побачити ще на менше висоти
турецького посла то його команду з нашої
україни і нашому цьому він струмені сечі ми в
розливі
і наш поліцейський так вирішив.
нехай кучму різниця між twitter ством
на дивані то управлінням краї знайти всіх
чого криє окраїною toomai то біля хвали
от і розумні рішення
йому вірна прямого права тата листя у
нідерландах доктус приймаючи мало на iq
початок кинься євросоюзу просто
політолога
народити покладати вона факти вона емоції
африці немає з'їзд пророку вали часто ало
я наберу ще дати його dee d
buy навіть як завершувати всі вибори в
нідерландах аргументи паніці ревниві
тримай листівок і партія вілдерса може
нехай їсть і перший обидва місця на
виборах 15 березня
адже його за мало щуп самостійно
сформувати шкоду від вернеш коаліцію
замші ми політична сила набутий край
проблематично народжує на радикальний
погляди вілдерса навіть прогнози
політологів за галон для с
оптимістичніше у бородюк призових сферах
вимагатиме жерлом євро скептицизму в
Європі ситуація кулі вшивається і набряки
щура біженців із буду по дону євросоюз
вище за все поверни своє право влада
вразливою це marco rizzi
за кілька рок і в'їзд куриш за все
ставали ґрунтованими
кордони будуть nadine узах ще ні ми
мою єдину валюту та банки у скінах ляд
теж стабільніше з силом можна при 1 ви
значимість у зміні ще й на політиках
досьє розв'язали нахабні проблеми на
вимкнена вкажіть на так і ще у або
захід плані право популістами
нас правді вже досягла свого піку